here in burkina faso these delicate
plants are already sprouting later
they'll create a dense forest to stop
the spread of the Sahara Desert
Peter fun Midwood works for a Berlin
based IT firm right now he's in Burkina
Faso to see if the trees are doing okay
his company is financing the
reforestation project
5,000 kilometers away in the Berlin
offices over cozier there's another
baobab sprouting Peter brought back some
seeds from Africa as a souvenir the IT
company is trying to generate as much
money as possible for reforestation
projects I think the trees are something
that are special trees are one of these
things in life that you only miss when
they're gone so a lot of people in the
Western world they take twist for
counters their natural leisure and in
nature and they don't realize that away
provide us with water they provide us
with many nuts they provide us with
timber is so many things coming from it
[Music]
Nicosia is a search engine like Google
or Bing the site allows users to search
for information or products users see
advertising between the search results
when they click on it a cozia earns
money which its founder Christian Cole
invests in trees
there are a few ads that are much more
valuable than other ads so if you search
for you know buying a new telephone car
even then a click could generate maybe
even a few euros in revenue for us which
means there would be a lot of trees just
because of one click most visitors to
the site are from France and Germany but
consumers in the u.s. also turned to the
search engine users like being able to
help the environment with just one click
around 80 percent of the revenue goes to
a cozy as reforestation projects its
employees earn average salaries more
importantly they feel they're
contributing to a better world but they
have a long road ahead the goal is to
plant a billion trees by 2020 they've
currently reached 7.6 million they're
constantly updating the tally new
reforestation projects are beginning to
take off in several parts of Africa the
awesome bara mountains of northeastern
Tanzania are another example PETA
returned from the region just a few days
ago mountains this small local company
they contacted us explaining that
they've planted half a million trees
last year but that they cooked much much
more together with all the local farmers
they're working with and they're
planting local trees in biodiversity
hotspot that is very precious so we got
to know each other better and together
we worked on a contract and now we're
going to plant three million trees we've
done still this year in Tanzania in
using our mountains
in recent decades large areas of the
ancient forests have been destroyed it
costs just 30 cents to plant a tree here
even so it'll take many more internet
searches and advertising clicks before
everything is green and lush again
[Music]